february lasts
forever i don't care if it's the
shortest shortest month shortest
shortest month you can show me all the
math in the world
i still don't believe it this month is
interminable
in fact
you want to know how bad
february is
my mother cut this out for me
it's a freaking
garfield strip
of all things
or it's just
it's
just it's practically the same panel all
that moves is his pupils and it's
garfield looking haggard over a cup of
coffee he says i'm in a bad mood
and its name is february
accurate
oh boy
set that aside
hi
everybody hope you're doing well
i'm trying to get all my stuff pulled
together for um
for my taxes
never look forward to that
ah
but i hope folks are doing okay
and yes congratulations to jody whitaker
um on her pregnancy yes i did hear about
that
let's send winter forever wait we're
already doing that oh diana now you're
making me sad
ah
um
so
i'm
i'm gonna try and be more upbeat i know
i i know i've been kind of
grouchy
uh the last couple streams
i don't mean to be
like seriously this is just not a great
time of year for me
uh hundreds thompson said february was
always the coolest month no basketball
no football
those things wouldn't help it wouldn't
help me at any rate geez
uh star wars indulgence on cameos and
surprise appearances and the way people
are just eating it really starts to
leave a bitter taste in my mouth i'm
like
i'm not sure how much of the upcoming
slate of um
of star wars stuff i'm actually to watch
and review because
most of it's probably all going to be
tied in
to a similar degree
to what is annoying me in book of boba
fett i'll watch the obi-wan
one
and maybe
the cassian andor one
maybe
the rest of them
i i feel like they want me to do
homework
and i'm
don't want to do homework
so
yeah
uh
yeah
yeah ben
that
uh
i don't care how grumpy you are you are
beautiful you are valuable thank you
ah thank you michael i appreciate that
let's get brown to the brass tacks how
do you feel about the boba fett show not
having any books like it barely has boba
fett anymore like at this point it's
just false advertising all the way down
um
what okay you're just naming muppet
movies at me for goodness sake uh
excuse me reminder um
while i do try and keep up with the chat
uh
the only thing that guarantees a
response is a super chat which will also
get you a heart from me well that and if
you're on the uh council of d
why can't i talk council of geeks
discord
uh there is also a channel there where
you can ask a question and i'll address
those a little bit later
that's how star trek feels to me so i
just don't bother with it
yeah and like here's the thing while i
do take in all the mcu stuff and like it
people are starting to say like they
feel like it's too much and
i get it
i don't feel that way about the mcu but
i get it
well cad bane needed to be there did he
though
did he really
i'm legitimately asking i don't know who
he is
i know nothing about him aside from that
appearance so
i don't know
maybe he did i wouldn't know
it doesn't feel like he'll be in front
of 30 littles in a month
my goodness
that's um
hey vera do you ever listen to the allen
parsons project i don't believe i have
i know it exists did
uh i if i've ever heard an allen parsons
project song
i don't know what it is
if you watch the clone wars series i
didn't watch the clone wars series
that's my point
they're now adding things in to a brand
new series that only means anything to
people who watched a completely
different series that wasn't even in the
same format because it was animated and
yes i know the continuity holds but like
i
uh
i'm trying i'm trying to not be grumpy i
swear
does that mug say what you think is that
yes bailey yes it does
well spotted
one of my best friends made a comic and
it's doing really well on amazon well
that's great
uh kj's anna glad to hear that
tried to watch clone wars and bad batch
i just couldn't bring myself to care see
i never got into clone wars
um initially because i didn't really
have a means to watch it while it was
airing and then later on it was just
it's like too much of a backlog i
couldn't uh
i couldn't really bring myself to commit
that much raspberry if you want some oh
open up
i did try bad badge i think i did three
episodes a bad batch
and i wasn't vibing with it and that
also kind of shut off the idea of me
getting into clone wars because i'm like
if this is the vibe of clone wars it's
fine but i don't love it
it's not multiple seasons worth
to me you know
i already said this on twitter but the
major oscar snub that made me want to
punch a wall was spark's not getting an
original song
a nomination for a net
i don't know annette so
um
sorry
i have no opinion
have ever seen the movie annihilation
yes annihilation
annihilation is a movie that i love
and it took me about a week
after seeing it to make up my mind that
i loved it
cause that movie
that movie took some work
you could say the same thing about nuhu
when they referenced classic who and
then you have a choice either let the
references fly over ahead or watch the
older stuff
i don't think that's equivocal here's
why
most of the time
when old stuff from the classic era
shows up in modern
era doctor who they also explain what it
is
it will mean more
if you have watched the old stuff but
like
when the dalek showed up in series one
they explained who the daleks were
and it worked even if all you knew was
the doctor out of history with them that
was covered in that episode and that's
been the general pattern so if you're
someone who needs to know all the
specifics then yes maybe you feel like
you're missing something but if you're
somebody like me who is equally happy to
just have a sense of
oh this is something from their past and
not necessarily needing to know the
specifics of their past
i i think it i think modern era doctor
who does it in a way that is perfectly
accessible for the most part i will say
that like
there hasn't really been a new jumping
on point
where you could start watching modern
day doctor who that you would not
eventually
have to go back to
series one
and then watch through the rest of
modern who because it's self-referential
within its own timeline
quite a bit it does expect you to know
all that so like say
when jack harkness
showed up in series 12 if you had
started watching doctor who
in series 11 or even
oh god heck how long have been since
jacksonville if you had started watching
series five with matt smith
and had never gone back and i'm not
saying like this is a thing that people
do but
theoretically if you had started
watching doctor who anywhere from series
five forward
then captain jack shows up if you ever
come back and watch that you have no
idea who he is and that scene means
nothing if you don't know who he is
and that's kind of the way that the cad
bane scene played to me i clearly was
expected to know who this was
but i didn't
there are ways to bring in
older things and revisit older things
and reference all of the things that
doesn't make it feel like
for newer viewers like i'm just missing
something there are ways to meet both
needs
my nails are pretty thank you oh that
one's chipped gotta redo that one
bad batch is actually darker than clone
wars
okay
i've ever watched a movie called the
breakfast club not only have i watched
the breakfast club i was in a stage
version of breakfast club in college
still need to see the owl house i'm told
it's a little gravity falls the owl
house is if
the owl house is what you would get if
harry potter was rebooted by the people
who made gravity falls
that's that's the owl house
ooh breakfast club breakfast club is i
think probably
um
along with maybe planes trains and
automobiles the john hughes movie that
has aged the best or
more appropriately aged the least badly
because some of his other stuff
boy
i
john hughes was a talented guy and like
i know his work was seminal for a lot of
people but
oh boy
theater ah yes yeah i had a lot of fun
uh
being in that too oh god i haven't been
on stage
in a sh in a play
in ages
i mean like last year i got to start um
doing burlesque again but i haven't
god when was the last time
last time i was in a play was
the odd couple
i was one of the poker players that was
what that was 20
[Music]
17
i think
i don't know it's
it's been a while
uh
don't you
forget about me
[Music]
one of my favorite movies ever it's a
good movie
it's enjoyable
have i seen she's having a baby no have
not seen that one
question do the mcu
suits seem overly designed to anyone
else or am i just weird um
depends on what you consider
to be over designed like they're
they're designed for film
i mean clearly
so
there's there's a lot going on often
that you know is only intended to be
seeing you know
these bits kind of catch the light in
certain moments or whatnot
um
i mean i'm not gonna say you're wrong
that they're over designed they're a
little bit but not in a way that i
personally feel like you want to over
design i
steppenwolf from either version of
justice league is over design
my favorite article of clothing
i don't know
what one's the most fun to take off
i'm told there's a theory and subtle
suggestion that eda from owl house and
stand from gravity falls were married
i don't believe that i believe there's a
theory i don't believe that that's a
thing
um like there are references there are
there
are mixed references between allah house
amphibia
um gravity falls they they reference
each other there was a gargoyle's
reference in one of them
uh i think an amphibia yeah no that
there's there's lots of intermingling
but it is just um it is just references
have i ever reviewed midnight mass i
haven't seen midnight mass so
no no
i have not reviewed it will i be
reviewing cobra kai season four
i mean i'd have to watch it and after
season three i kind of don't wanna
like maybe eventually i'm not in any
rush
uh my younger sibling came out as
non-binary i'm very worried about the
school seminar we had an expert on lgbtq
people she was teaching us acceptance
she was also cis and straight
well
and keep in mind a cis-straight person
is not incapable of understanding or
being able to educate on matters of
um queer identity and queer acceptance
sometimes if that's the best you've got
you take what you can get
um
best of luck to your sibling
absolutely
fingers crossed it really does vary
wildly from
area to area some places like it's not
an issue some places it is
new type jb lee thank you very much for
the super chat how are you comic
question thoughts on the hobgoblin
um do you think he was almost as good as
the green goblin or better in terms of
villainy here's the problem
uh here's why i can't ask that because
you asked about a specific iteration of
the hobgoblin
and there have been too many
there have been like four hobgoblins and
i don't know any of them that well
so
and i really don't know what roderick
kingly did in specific
like i know the original hobgoblin was
ned leeds
and then i know
i don't know if roderick was next and
then i know the hobgoblin actually got
possessed by a goblin but then got split
from that goblin and that became the the
demo goblin but there was also still a
hobgoblin i don't know if that was still
him or if that was somebody else and
then i think there was somebody else
after that hob goblins
convoluted
one of the more convoluted
spider-man
uh villains if we're being honest
the only thing of note with she's having
a baby is that john hughes asked kate
bush to write a song for it and she gave
us this woman's work a song that gets me
every time
okay
someone over at fire water reviewed
midnight mass i want to say either rob
or ryan i could be wrong i could i could
see them actually double teaming on that
my gut feeling would be rob um but i
don't know
favorite alcoholic beverage uh
whatever's cheap
as long as it's not beer
uh she also told us gender fluid people
are just questioning and are not real
ah
well
[ __ ]
that's oh
[ __ ]
that is
that's a bad
sign all right um
i'm sorry
i am sorry that the person who is
educating
in your area on
lgbtqia
identities
is flatly shutting some of them down
because
it shows an inherent
misunderstanding
of what people can be
just questioning and not real
number one speaking of someone who has
identified as genderfluid for going on
seven years now pretty real last i
checked and number two feel free to clip
this and send this a tour
don't really well go go ahead if you
want to number two
to say that it's just questioning is to
diminish anyone who's questioning and
implying that that is less valid
questioning is valid as hell i think
everybody should question their gender
regardless of whether or not you decide
no i actually am cisgender everybody
should question that question your
assumptions figure out and be firm and
solid and certain about where you are
and if you're not certain take as much
time as you want you can be questioning
for 50 years you are valid
hey
what do i think of the movie heavy metal
it's fun
it's not good but it's fun
the anti-trans movement is very loud so
much stuff on youtube and i avoid all of
it like the plague
uh
discovering i was genderfluid was when i
stopped questioning my gender i was in
my 30s there you go
there you go john vinyls thank you
kindly
have i read the graphic novel the girl
from the sea or played the game uh what
remains of edith finch i recommend them
both
yes and no respectively if you check out
fireandwaterpodcast.com
and look up the
uh tough like a girl podcast liz and i
reviewed the girl from the sea so yes i
have read that i have not played what
remains of edith finch
i like the soundtrack to heavy metal
what's funny about the soundtrack to
heavy metal is that it was the reason
that the movie was really hard to get
for like 15 years
because there were so many bands
involved in that soundtrack that getting
the music right sorted to actually have
a proper home release it took them
forever to sort that out
um
this is meant to be a funny question but
sorry if it gets serious
if you got canceled for something what
would it be
i
i i'm not going to indulge that question
um
if i was in a more playful mood i could
give you a playful answer
like
i'll get canceled because
i'll say well maybe i'm already getting
cancelled for saying that the uh
mandalorian parts of book of boba fett
are the worst parts of boba fett i'm
practically getting canceled for that
that would be my jokey response an
honest response um i'm going to pass on
because
there is
there is enough that i regret
about
own
history and being
almost 40 years old
i've got
more than enough years of being
a [ __ ]
that are at this point well in my rear
view
but if i was going to seriously get
cancelled
that's that's where my head goes
so there you go
i think a better way to say it to me is
the mcu suits seem less iconic you know
i think that varies from suit to suit
i think what's very telling is that
there it's almost never the same suit
one film to the next they they
tweak them almost every time so
they don't really get the chance to be
iconic like aspects become iconic
um like the shield becomes iconic
um just the look of the helmet
on iron man becomes iconic but the
specifics aren't
uh what do i think of the latest dune
movie i did a review when it came out
it was good i didn't
lose my mind
over it
the way
seemingly every other reviewer on
youtube has done
it was fine it was good even but like i
don't think it was the most amazing
thing ever
uh
what makes me so wise nothing
nothing i am no
wiser inherently
than anyone else
i
i do my best
to impart what i understand
as best as i understand it
with the caveat that i understand a very
limited scope of things
i try and be
aware and open about my own limitations
so
i kind of i resist the idea of being
called wise because that gives me the
idea that people
would turn to me for
knowledge and insight which i don't feel
qualified to give
just because i
know myself
and i know my own faults
and so
and when that is the case it can be
it can be hard to
take that view on yourself
which may be a good thing
in some respects
ms wiggles can i bite my eyelashes i can
i'm not going to because i'm not your
trained monkey
what do i think about the cgi luke
skywalker being used more prominently in
his own show for example
i know
that's a terrible idea
no please don't do that
i already think they used him way way
way way more than they should have
so
ah
i know that i know nothing
i don't
see i don't think i know nothing but i
know i will never know everything
and neither will anyone else
do i like stevie wonder yeah he's all
right
early stuff i tend to favor
well without contradicting you that is a
very thoughtful answer good approach to
the things
thank you
uh
yeah i'm trying to think
what's been going on lately well
tomorrow's the last episode of book of
boba fett
and i'm hoping it won't annoy me what am
i munching on i'm munching on uh bits of
raspberry
um
but then that'll be done
i'll be i'll be done with um
stuff on disney plus for a little bit
actually
i think till next month
and then uh peacemaker wraps up
so
yeah
that's what i've got coming down the
pike
i'm going to try and get back into final
fantasy 7
remake um
on twitch again tomorrow
i might
i might take a break like i want to get
through i want to get through the um don
corneo stuff
cause i've been really excited to see
how that's gonna be reimagined
but
after that i might honestly take a break
because i'm not
i'm not as engaged with it as i would
like to be
how far have i gotten into final fantasy
7 remake i am i have just started the
don corneo uh subplot
um
cast is all right i mean it's
it's weird because the more i think
about it the more i realized like they
don't speak particularly differently
from how they did in the original
it's just those lines
worked much better
um
to read them than to hear a human being
say them
can we talk about hardcore hardcore is
great
uh liz has started watching
um peacemaker she hasn't caught up yet
but harcourt's her favorite huge
surprise the uh the
the [ __ ] blonde her words not mine
it's her favorite character what a shock
um la minia
i think that's an l that's either a
lowercase l or capital i so maybe it's
i am mania
either way thank you so much for the
super chat and a very cool sticker i dig
it
jon vinyls thank you as well
got a favorite video game or genre of
video games i'm partial to her
interactive's nancy drew games i mean my
favorite video game of all time
is probably going to stay final fantasy
6
just because he can't beat nostalgia
the game i've spent the most time
playing is hades
which is very good and
like i at this point i'm just in general
i'm retro
in terms of my gaming preferences
um
i
you know i like something 2d
i like
isometric um i like platformers i like
um
i i like uh turn-based rpgs
even point-and-click adventure games
like i like games that are taking their
cues from the 90s basically
mountain harpy member for two months yes
thank you very much at the snazzy
supporter level much appreciated
ariel parker doesn't bang peacemaker
yeah i'm kinda hoping to
like they're starting to lean that way i
hope i hope she doesn't
i try to do the same i stress in a video
where i bring up a psychology study that
i wasn't trying to pretend that i know
everything just having fun applying
stuff that interests me
um oh mountain heartbeat ooh
i got some hearts straight back thank
you so much
very appreciated what's been my favorite
dc eu project so far
depends am i allowed to limit it to
single films or do i have to pick a
franchise because if i can say
just the first wonder woman and don't
have to take 1984 on board then it's
going to be just the first wonder woman
not taking 1984 on board um
[Music]
but
i don't know the dcu
has kind of topped out at it was pretty
good for me
like
snyder cut was way better than i thought
it would be but i don't ever need to
watch it again
aquaman was fun because it embraced its
insanity
um but it wasn't an amazing movie it was
just more fun than i thought it was
going to be first wonder woman was
really good except for the climax is a
bit of a whiff but
uh more and more in execution than in
theory
however checked out seconds by brian lee
o'malley
they would be a good fit for tough like
a girl
i think it's on the docket
i say that like you need to realize the
docket is dozens of things long and
we've been
doing this podcast for years already and
we only do one a month so we go through
stuff very very quickly
uh
and i mean
see i know brian lee o'malley is also
the writer on
scott pilgrim
what would i think of the actress that
played sylvie to play the 14th doctor
um
i mean they won't for one simple reason
she's also
uh an attractive uh blonde woman so
simply for the sake of
um shaking things up visually they won't
now that's not to say they shouldn't
because
you know when they cast matt smith it
was a young skinny guy with brown hair
what was david tennant a young skinny
guy with brown hair but like that's
gonna be the approach
they're they're not gonna they're gonna
treat it like an issue there whereas
they wouldn't with got and haven't
with dudes
um but no she could be good
like just in general
karen's a good game i've heard carrion
um
is an interesting game i've seen some of
the game play i've also heard it's a
game where it's very easy to get lost
and i have a tendency to do that even in
games that don't have a reputation
for being easy to get lost in so that's
my that is my um
hesitance on trying uh carrion i mean
maybe if it's on sale sometime i'll pick
it up cheap or something
i was planning to see imagine dragons in
milwaukee
uh
but considering the state of the city as
of late that's out of the question ooh
assuming that it's in not great shape
i finally found classical and started
watching it's definitely uh being
watched in a non-pirated way yes
i'm sure it is cora
i ain't i
i
i don't um
i don't pirate
i don't judge most people who do
some people with the attitude they have
about it i do um but i i don't i don't
do it
less because i'm above it and more
because
it requires more technical savvy than i
actually feel like putting in
i would rather pay the fee and just get
it on on a legit service
software isn't on my docket well
i can be adjusted
did i ever consider making more good
movie bad ending weirdly i found a lot
of games not films uh that fit it costs
far cry 3. um
i mean i've still got a list of possible
movies to talk about that i think it was
it was never a particularly successful
series
i think the best chance of good movie
bad ending ever coming back is if
it is if i see
a newer movie
that fits that description
so that i can be topical because
like the various movies i've got jotted
down as potential
uh ones to talk about on that are old
and you know
the algorithm would
bury the video
and
in some cases i've kind of addressed
elsewhere
like um
training day was on my list but i kind
of addressed my issues with training day
when i did my video on
um
faux complexity with villains
so
any plans to tackle anime
no
i like anime just fine don't get me
wrong but like
there are not enough hours in the day
for me to get a steady anime diet in
to my life
i only pirate shows i can't physically
watch in my country and that i
definitely get behind
john vinyls once again thank you not
sure if i already asked you this but how
much um did you know about henry viii
and his six wives before listening to
the musical six
a bit not a ton but a bit
excuse me
um
so
like i know i know more about them than
i did because of that show but i did i
did know
some things i'd probably forgotten about
as many things as i'd learned honestly
but
if aliens attacker don't believe it
i mean
will they do anything worse to the earth
than what we're already doing
just saying
this is why i prefer anime movies over
series i watch a thing for a couple of
hours but 17 seasons is a bit much
see i feel that way and also i find in
general that
anime
[Music]
series and shows are far more likely to
dip into the
um
aspects and trappings of anime that i
don't like so much whereas those things
don't
seep into the movies as often
um
in terms of some of the
like the the movies often tend to be
more restrained
in a way that works better for me
there's a possibility that last night in
soho might be a movie you could do a
good movie bad ending about i gotta find
out oh i'm gonna find out when that hits
uh streaming or the cost of renting it
goes down i gotta check one of those
i want joe martin to be the 14th doctor
so bad you and me both
uh
last
night in
soho
streaming
uh six buck rental
you're gonna wait for that to come down
wait to see what services it ends up on
uh
oh hey adrenaline glad you made
it they don't want to attack us but we
need a reason to weaponize space do we
really need a reason i i assumed that
was something that we're just going to
end up doing
because you know
my biggest pet peeve
i don't know if it's my biggest but the
one that has historically come up the
most often
is if we meet
and i'm sure and you introduce yourself
to me and i introduce yourself to you
and i say hi my name's nathaniel and you
then proceed to call me by anything
other than that such as nate nathan nat
or anything like that
uh we gonna have a problem
because i told you how to
address me i said my name is nathaniel
meaning that's what i want you to call
me
don't short my name
i have other names that i'll answer to
but not a shortening of that one
missed you last friday but hope you're
feeling much better i i am like i was i
uh last week was just not great
in general
that's
true truth be told
um
excuse me
uh
worst part isn't when we weaponize
spaces when we put a subway there
[Laughter]
uh
five dollar space foot long
kyle kalgren did a terrific video on the
league of extraordinary gentlemen
series that really goes into the
problematic stuff that moore puts in
there
yeah i'm gonna
at some point
um hopefully this year
liz and i are gonna tackle a an alan
moore book for tough like a girl uh
we're gonna do promethea which i think
other than lost girls which we're
definitely not doing might be the only
alan moore book that fits the remit of
that podcast which is that it has to
have a female protagonist
capitalism in space ugh
allowing human beings to spread the
plague that is their existence
uh
mad respect for the for the full name
yeah and like i don't even have like a
story behind that or anything i just
like i never went by a nickname so
i just don't like it
uh update on the mom versus anime
situation she's taking me to an anime
convention in a couple of weeks
hopefully she won't be too judgmental oh
that's good
fingers crossed on that
of color should play the next doctor i i
would agree with that
have i read have i
have i read any books by christopher
moore
um i haven't i've i've missed like his
last four or five but
i have
a whole
mess of his books
uh including lamb
in hardcover um
trying to think i've got
i've read practical demon keeping coyote
blue
bloodsucking feeds the love story and
it's two sequels i've read fluke i've
read lamb i read fool
uh lust lizard of millie colin cove
island of the sequined love nun
i think that's all of his stuff that
i've read
uh no stupidest angel so that's 11.
um
i haven't
i i started
blue
but i didn't finish it
so
11 and a half
of his books i like christopher moore a
lot um i haven't read any of his stuff
in a while but i i
historically i have liked christopher
moore
quite a bit
lamb especially lamb oh
lamb is special
so folks um
if folks don't know the book lamb
the gospel according to biff
christ's childhood pal
by christopher moore
[Laughter]
i love that book so much
um
what's great about it is that it's
actually
incredibly
respectful
of jesus the figure in specific
but just takes the piss with pretty much
everything else
um
it's it's really nicely done now of
course like not being a christian having
never identified as a christian i'm not
gonna say that like there's nothing to
be offended by but as someone who is
usually decent at recognizing the sorts
of things where something
really crosses the line is disrespectful
i felt like his depiction of jesus
himself was incredibly respectful it's
just the whole thing is told through the
lens of a character with almost no
redeeming features at all and it's great
it's so good
have i listened to any of the doctor who
audiobooks i've listened to one i have
listened to
ah
prisoner of the daleks
that's the only one i've listened to
um
john vinyls once again thank you so much
for the super chat i greatly appreciate
it
what if
girl from the sea ended with morgan
turning into a selkie and going to live
with
kelty beneath the sea for the rest of
her life eternity um
i mean
for that to work
we would have the the book would have to
be changed in a way to express a desire
on her part to do that specifically we
would have to know about know more about
the situation she was getting into
um
for that to work
if the book was simply presented the way
as is but that was the ending i don't
think it would work it would need
massaging on the content up to that
point to make that work uh
excited for the batman
not
not
exceptionally
here's the thing
the batman might be good it might even
be great
but it is a
version and a vision
of
um
batman that i'm just i'm tired of
i remember when batman stories were fun
and i'm very tired of them
being
dark and brutal
all the
time and i'm not saying those can't
still be good
i just kind of need a break
so no i'm not super excited
i know other people are and that's
another thing that like i'm getting
hammered on i'm getting hammered on for
not liking uh the mandalorian stuff and
i get hammered on for being skeptical
about the batman
like people downvote my skepticism about
that movie so much
um
if i can recommend a review of final
fantasy 7 remake
7
final fantasy 7 remake i can talk
by maximilian dude
he's a huge ff7 fan who knows how much
extra stuff uh that'll make a lot of
stuff make sense i mean maybe when i
take a break from it
sounds like dogma yeah if you like dogma
check out lamb for sure
um
did i see the new trailer for the pixar
movie uh light year i did
i was unimpressed by it but then again
i'm usually unimpressed by pixar
trailers that's actually the norm for me
so that kind of means nothing either way
ah
nice pull john i like that
all i am is jesus brother bob
jesus brother bomb jesus brother bob but
nobody relative of the son of god
if only i've been born
just a little sooner
i'd be more than the brother of god
junior
[Music]
the arrogant worms
if you don't know them look them up
good to see you too cora you take care
i think it's the case if you're a
christian who isn't offended by life of
brian you won't be offended by lamb yeah
that's that's a good measure
uh thank you captain omni thank you very
much do i think jurassic park dinosaurs
still count as dinosaurs on a textbook
level despite being confirmed genetic
creations rather than clones
for the purposes of entertainment yes
for the purposes of scientific
classification no
uh
you like soul and luca i did
i
i usually like
um
pixar movies but like their trailers
almost never do it for me
i actually like that you go against the
commons re boba fett and the batman
because that means you care enough to be
disappointed sure that's one
interpretation i'll take it
uh
oh michael anderson doyle thank you very
much all hail queen nathaniel thank you
i appreciate that
see this is why i'm getting all my
controversial takes out
while no one knows who i am eg moffatt
wrote the daleks well and the time
meddler's overrated oh boy yeah you
better get those out of your system
before anyone starts watching
[Music]
a new type jb lee thank you very much do
you prefer 70s era batman by o'neal and
adams i
i see i prefer
the batman the animated series batman
because it was dark and it had its edge
but it didn't forget to be fun like he
could tell dark stories but not
everything was dark
oh jim sends thank you very much just
because oh
thank you ah
sorry give me one second folks i will be
right back
okay thank you for your patience are
there any
tropes everyone else is sick of but you
still like for me it's zombies uh ones
that run and scream and are scary there
probably are some i'm drawing a blank
off the top of my head though
you can only choose one labyrinth of the
neverending story elaborate that's not
even close
conroy is the best batman and the best
wayne he is but can i can i be slightly
controversial on that
only in that series
because they have they have made a habit
of bringing conroy in
to other batman projects
where he doesn't work
because they are far darker
than his batman makes sense in and his
performance doesn't work
i love kevin conroy in the batman
animated series and it's direct
continuations and things linked to that
continuity but once they had him start
doing things like batman and the killing
joke and batman and the arkham games
it
doesn't work because
these stories are far
far too dark
for his iteration of batman they were
built for a different batman but they
used him
and it doesn't fully work the degree to
which it doesn't work
varies
but i i i have to put that asterisk
on kevin conroy he is the best but only
in the show where his
performance was tailored to the material
because since then
no
not really
captain omni again thank you so very
much
as a follow-up do you think michael
crichton just had a problem with theme
parks give it two of his best known
works take the piss out of theme parks
maybe
i didn't realize that yeah you're right
cause that in westworld
uh
but yes ooh um okay so i was asked what
my favorite scary movie is i don't know
if it's my favorite but the scariest
movie is the 1970s version of invasion
of the body snatchers gotta check the
discord i will be right back
see what we've got here
uh
it's the it's at least the shortest
month but it contains one of the fake
holidays i hate and is rather depressing
to me due to how many people think it's
about dating etc etc ah i assume you
mean valentine's day valentine's day is
one of those things that like i've
always just kind of been like oh yeah
right that thing
this is kind of where i always land with
that
um
if you haven't seen if you have
if you haven't seen it yeah here have an
opinion on something you haven't seen
learn to read if you've seen it thoughts
on superman and lois i haven't so i have
none uh over one season and i still
can't believe that the thing i was
planning to rip the shreds since it was
announced is actually great i've heard
good things about it i have not gotten
to it yet
uh going to have to agree to disagree
about star about clone wars and bad
batch but i can understand not wanting
to commit to five seasons worth of lore
it's a testament to your even handedness
that i can
do that and feel better about it than
with anyone else i appreciate that that
said has there ever been a series or
movies you swore you would never watch
only to watch them and realize they were
better or worse than you expected
uh
probably
um
i mean
it's not it's probably not the best
example but off the top my head like i
was i was
dead certain
that wonder woman was gonna suck
i was real sure about that
uh and it didn't it was really good
um oh aaron thank you so much aaron oh
just want to say cool earrings oh thank
you i love these
i like these a lot i've been wearing
them a lot since i got them
uh jon vinyls once again thank you so
much
was just thinking about whether you
could do casino royale for good movie
bad ending
see the the thing about casino royale
its ending isn't bad but it's ending us
to another movie but the thing about
casino royale is it's already three
different movies
so that's actually not a problem
restricted to the ending
because you know the entire thing right
up until
the plane explosion
is
uh
is something of a high octane action
movie
and then it's a slow burn espionage
movie during the entire time it's at the
casino
and then it's uh
it's a tragic
chase film
for the last one it's three different
movies
so the disjointedness which i do think
is a problem isn't restricted to the end
if you get what i mean
captain omni once again thank you very
much
batman bravo bold has the best batman
seriously some episodes showed he can be
dark but still clearly loved fighting
crime and the adventure i caught a
couple of episodes of that it looked
like a lot of fun
um i didn't have the time to get more
into it but uh that was
that that was a fun one i'm definitely
glad that that exists i'll say that
uh
i love the way you rolled your r when
you said right back right back yep
it it always throws me off like how many
people can't do that
like my kid can't do that her mother
can't do that
liz can't do that
oh well
that makes me sad cause that means they
can't purr
or or uh cool like a dove
[Music]
do i like sitcoms
i'm picky i'm picky about sitcoms new
type jb lee thank you very much
uh how come you're not a fan of the
nastiness of ditko era spidey isn't the
harsh sense of alienation is what
peter's so unique from other silver age
heroes
the issue is is less
that peter himself has that
it's that
all right how do i word this
it's not an inherent problem
for your hero to have
a bad outlook
or a
bad world view
where that becomes a problem is when the
narrative seems to agree
and feel that that isn't a bad world
view and a bad outlook
because it's honestly fundamentally the
exact same problem that a lot of 90s
comic books had now in 90s it was more
pronounced and way more prevalent
because you had all these incredibly
nasty pieces of work who were basically
the hero just by authorial decree like
between these two warring factions of
people with oversized guns and way too
many pouches who always swear and are
always grumpy and don't get along and
kill anyone who opposes them this one is
the good guys so you know it was
completely arbitrary but you would have
a ton of these heroes or things being
billed as anti-heroes who weren't even
really that
and you know with this idea of oh but
he's he's nasty and and like kills
people like
but that's not interesting if the
narrative agrees that that with that
character's outlook and frames that as a
good thing that's one of the things that
a lot of writers get wrong about the
punisher
the punisher
we should enjoy watching him work but we
shouldn't ever feel like he's right
completely and i think that's more my
issue with ditko era spider-man it's
less that peter was
nasty and bitter and isolationist it's
that the framing made it seem like
they wanted the reader to feel he was
right
to think that and that's what i have a
problem with [ __ ] era spider-man
uh rachel loretto a couple more of these
and then we gotta wrap it up soon uh
can't wait for your your review
uh in another life uh gal gara is in the
book
uh gal gara is in it the book made me so
disappointed
uh
find in another life i don't
i don't know if i've heard of that
i'm not sure if i know what that is
while i'm checking that
tara
tara staller thank you very much
um
uh did you see the movie come true so
would you think i had a spoiled for me
and i want an opinion from someone it
wasn't spoiled for i am not familiar
with that one it does not ring
a bell
so let me see here
oh mountain harpy thank you oh pine
trees lovely
um
meet me in another life
no i'm not familiar with that one
no i don't know what that is
favorite anti-hero
not sure i have one off the top of my
head
punisher can be justified but he can
never be right yeah that's kind of where
i'm coming at with that jack yeah you
said it more succinctly than i did
uh
i'm bypassing your dad joke
douglas
um
thank you very much john fun fact about
ditko he was an objectivist oh i know
i know
and if you read much of his work
especially his work after he left marvel
you too
will know
even if you don't know exactly what that
is you'll feel it
the holy cow will you feel it
um
do i have to be listening to something
while playing a game depends on the game
um
if it is something that like i'm i'm not
playing for the story then yes i might
have a podcast or a youtube video on or
something hello from the uk have i
watched twin peaks
no
i have not
uh favorite
non-batman
uh the animated series related animated
batman movie um
so stepping outside of that continuity
probably gods and monsters
i should watch that one again that one's
really good
one of my favorite actors is an
objectivist by all accounts so zack
snyder um
but also by all accounts zack snyder is
a very cool person to work with and a
nice human being which is weird because
ayn rand would hate that
so you know
uh whatever he couldn't possibly be any
worse than dave sim ooh god
you want to talk about a guy whose
issues bled into his work holy crap
uh tracy dale thank you so much
finally got seeing kanto and i've had
surface pressure stuck in my head for
days
brushing like a drip drip drip that'll
never stop
whoa
ah
so i am gonna wrap it up
thank you everybody for joining me this
was this actually this was kind of
it's kind of what i needed it to be this
was
light and this was pleasant and i feel
like i didn't get i didn't get too
grouchy too many times so i feel like i
feel good about this one
um
oh
mountain herpe thoughts on the concept
of the crossroads
i think you're gonna have to
i think you need to tell me what that is
because i'm not
the way you capitalize it makes me think
it's like a book or a movie or something
but i don't know
i don't know i don't know what that is
[Music]
okay pop on back there
oh i drank it all
ah
chow i'm off to rest after my booster
yes rest recover and it didn't hit me
too hard though
anyways
think about it answer me later concept
the concept of the crossroads okay i'm
gonna have to look into that um
but for right now oh yes uh thank thank
you carowind um so yes i'll be on twitch
tomorrow 10 30 a.m eastern time
playing final fantasy 7 remake
and um
yeah uh join me there if you are free
and able and i hope you all take good
care of yourselves and please remember
that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council's adjourned
my company